our biggest projects uh imminent
projects are we are adding six
sports fields or multi-use fields here
at craig ranch regional park uh one
contiguous park area that will encompass
six individual fields uh for uh sports
nothing and special events you don't
think um that project is being planned
master plan as we speak
and it will kick off probably in about
two months uh construction and it's
about a six-month build but those six
parks will be the largest contiguous
sports park that we have in north las
vegas
we're using xeriscape scenarios or
desert landscaping for like a better
word um in areas uh that have previously
not been
looked at
we the recent legislation from the state
of nevada required that the inactive
sports areas
somehow be
turf abated and removed that existing
green turf and put in more water
efficient xeriscaping or just
rock landscaping we're
integrating
the legislative uh mandate uh for
xeriscaping in all of our parks and
trails um we're anticipating the use of
artificial grass in a lot of areas now
we found a couple of grasses that the
snwa
prefers
requires less watering not just to keep
a little green but the whole focus in
our communities has been
limit the amount of grass
in the residential areas and bring the
citizens out to the parks to enjoy the
green grass
we're going to maintain that concept but
at the same time we're appropriate now
we'll make the xeriscape changes and
have turf abatement programs
to trim here and trim there but we will
always maintain large open space green
space
for the kids and families to come out
and enjoy pick next sporting events to
whatever the case may be